bonsoir là c'est RCI la commission
régionale de coopération intercommunale
vient d'adopter la proposition des élus
locaux de fonder un grand Saint-Quentin
à 12 communes dès le premier janvier
2007 souhaité par le préfet 2016
souhaité par le préfet de région la
super intercommunalité à 800 000
habitants et 57 communes à cheval sur
deux départements les Yvelines et le
département de l'Essonne a finalement
été abandonné cette édition du 7 8
politique sera donc consacrée à l'avenir
de l'agglomération nous verrons comment
va s'opérer le rapprochement dans les
prochains mois je reçois sur ce plateau
Michel logier le président de la
Communauté d'Agglomération de 50 ans en
Yvelines maire de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
bonsoir face à vous Joséphine Coleman
berger bonsoir la présidente de la
communauté de communes de l'Ouest
parisien maire de plaisir Grégory
garestier vice-président de la
Communauté de Communes des étangs de
Maurepas
Mirambeau bienvenue pour la première
fois d'ailleurs sur ce plateau
vice-président de la communauté de
communes de l'Ouest parisien maire de
Villepreux Véronique bonsoir
vice-président de la communauté de
communes de l'Ouest parisien mer
Clayes-sous-Bois et Henri Payet bonsoir
à vous vice-président de la Communauté
de Communes des étangs mère de
Coignières votre mariage à tous les 6
devrait se faire sauf surprise dans les
prochains mois globalement vous en êtes
plutôt satisfait sauf Henri Payet
peut-être vous souhaitiez rester dans
votre communauté de communes des étangs
que vous avez rejoint d'ailleurs il n'y
a pas très très longtemps ce mariage
avec 50 ans en Yvelines ce n'est pas une
aubaine pour vous donc ce n'est pas une
aubaine et c'est un scandale
vous connaissez mon front Paris je n'ai
pas la langue de bois et donc je
considère que nous ramener dans la vie
de nouvelles de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines que nous avons
quitté en 84 moyennant le paiement à la
vie de nouvelles en euros d'aujourd'hui
non en France de l'époque de plus de 150
millions de francs plus la feuille de
céder à la vue de la verrière 25
hectares de nos bonnes terre de
Coignières et bien je trouve qu'il est
scandaleux aujourd'hui de nous ramener
je dirais en ville nouvelle
partie de du 50 ans en Yvelines
historique des années 70 effectivement
Michel Laugier
c'est vrai qu'on a commencé avec Henri
Payet parce que c'est
allez-y
bien évidemment on va saisir ça on va
faire appel parce qu'il y a tout un tas
moi j'estime aujourd'hui que nous sommes
plus en démocratie nous sommes en
dictatures la relais voilà donc on va
faire appel de tout ça je ne sais pas
comment ça va se terminer
aussi par hasard on rejoint la ville de
l'oreille il est parfaitement clair que
l'on réclamera notre participation
financière de 150 millions de francs
plus les terres CD à La Verrière parce
que c'était une participation financière
à l'époque décidée par le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui était de faire et il est
parfaitement clair qu'aujourd'hui sur
une remède en ville nouvelle ça devient
du vol on va faire Michel legier tout de
même alors déjà d'une part c'est pas moi
qui fait la loi et c'est pas moi qui
suis ministre et moi je n'ai rien
réclamé à la ville de Coignières
puisqu'à l'époque je n'étais pas aux
affaires donc les choses se sont passées
dans les années 80 nous sommes
aujourd'hui en 2015 et nous devons
appliquer la loi c'est pas moi non plus
qui est voté la loi sur
l'intercommunalité en tout cas ce qu'on
peut voir quand même c'est que
contrairement à ce que dit en repailleux
moi je trouve que aujourd'hui on est
quand même une organisation qui me
paraît beaucoup plus adaptée que les 800
000 habitants auxquels
aussi faisait partie de ce schéma à 800
000 habitants donc aujourd'hui entre 800
000 on est à 230 000 je pense que
c'était déjà bien et on est sur un vrai
bassin de vie alors après la position
d'Henri que je connais depuis longtemps
et que j'apprécie aussi depuis longtemps
je le laisse responsable puisque il est
maire il est élu donc s'il veut aller en
Conseil d'État à lire en Conseil d'État
moi je suis là aussi pour appliquer la
loi et la loi aujourd'hui qui va
s'appliquer parce que aujourd'hui vous
savez nous sommes dans une première
victoire c'est-à-dire face au schéma des
préfets nous avons gagné puisque
l'amendement que nous avons déposé pour
revenir à des bassins de vie vraiment
adapté à nos territoires a été votée à
la quasi unanimité sauf que aujourd'hui
notre nouvelle interco n'existe pas il
va falloir attendre que la loi se
déroule il va falloir attendre que le
mois de décembre et ce serait en janvier
2016 pour ça sera comme ça en sachant
que aujourd'hui il y a aussi des
d'avancer législatives puisqu'il y a
d'autres lois qui touchent les
territoires et on parle aussi d'un
étalement dans le temps pour
l'application donc aujourd'hui en tout
cas moi je suis très pragmatique et je
pense que mes collègues maire et qui
sont là autour de cette table leçon
aussi donc nous ce que nous voyons c'est
que on ne voulait pas être absorbé dans
les buissons 1000 habitants et là
c'était déjà une première victoire pour
nous c'est déjà la victoire essentielle
pour revenir
du côté de Coignières le territoire
n'est pas encore adapté il préférait
rester de l'autre côté
on va continuer notre tour de table avec
peut-être les communes historiques tout
d'abord celles de plaisir elle faisait
partie également de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines dans les
années 70 jusqu'au début des années 80
vous vivez de la même manière qu'en
ripailleux
le territoire d'Élancourt qui
appartenait à plaisir
non non non on n'est pas on pas tout à
fait dans la même démarche même si je
respecte complètement ce que vient de
dire monsieur païeux mais il est clair
que nous on est dans cette dynamique
d'approche par rapport à 50 ans en
Yvelines pour tout ce qu'on a pu évoquer
toutes les fois qu'on a pu évoquer ce
sujet là c'est-à-dire cette intelligence
de territoire et puis cette dynamique
aussi que l'on a au niveau du bassin qui
soit commercial industriel et tous les
projets qu'on peut avoir ensemble et qui
sont des projets qui me semble tout à
fait pertinents aujourd'hui franchement
cohérent aujourd'hui même sentiment il y
a pas eu tout malgré tout du temps de
perdu parce que quitter l'agglomération
ça coûtait aussi de l'argent ça coûtait
des territoires sur Maurepas également
et puis finalement on y revient on n'a
pas perdu de temps 20-30 ans on a perdu
30 ans je pense en tout cas pour la
ville de Maurepas elle s'est construite
avec la ville nouvelle on en est sorti
évidemment dans les années 80 j'en suis
pas responsable parce que à l'époque
j'étais presque honnête voilà je suis
dans 82 donc voilà j'hérite aussi d'une
situation mais je vois que finalement le
bassin de vie de Maurepas est avec la
vie nouvelle elle a toujours été
nous avons essayé de construire quelque
chose avec la communauté de communes des
étangs voilà on s'aperçoit que
finalement on était dans une zone
transitoire puisque c'était en tout cas
la volonté du préfet et je pense que ça
a été finalement une erreur parce qu'on
se retrouve finalement dans le schéma
qui devait adopter il y a quelques
années
donc voilà moi ceci étant maintenant je
travaille pour l'avenir pour les morts
pasiens de construire voilà un vrai
projet de territoire et c'est ça
maintenant qui m'anime puisque voilà il
y a l'état il faut il y a des
discussions qui ont été faites on peut
en penser ce qu'on veut mais voilà c'est
comme ça
pour voilà je respecte aussi Henry qui a
envie de défendre aussi c'est ses
intérêts et la volonté qu'il a pour son
territoire en tout cas pour Maurepas et
puis pour les mortasiens voilà je
défendrai en tout cas nos intérêts dans
une communauté d'agglomération qui quand
même est très dynamique évidemment qui
est source de dynamisme d'emploi mais
aussi en termes de projet
sportif on le voit avec le vélodrome
donc voilà il y a il y a plein de points
positifs
peut-être de ce futur
à 12 communes tout d'abord pour le pour
la mairie de Villepreux Stéphane mis en
bois et puis après je vous ferai réagir
Véronique pour les clés rejoindre
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour vous ce
sera une première comme pour l'éclair
d'intégrer ce territoire ça représente
quoi ce sera un dynamisme nouveau pour
la commune vous en attendez quoi en tout
cas j'en attends beaucoup de choses et
un nouveau projet qui j'espère va être
construit avec beaucoup de
responsabilités de la part des
différents élus qui vont être impliqués
moi je dis que la loi c'est la loi nous
devons nous réunir en intercommunalité
c'est vrai que le choix de
Saint-Quentin pour nous Villepreux
Villepreux est une ville qui est à la
croisée des
territoires nous avons des liens avec
Versailles Grand Parc nous avons des
liens avec Saint-Germain-en-Laye ou
salon de la protège nous avons des liens
évidemment avec plaisir et les clés sous
bois nous aurions certainement aimé
rester seul nous ne pouvons pas nous
avons tout fait et je crois que nous
avons supporté la contestation parce que
le projet de 800 000 habitants était une
absurdité et nous avons montré que quand
les se réunissent ensemble on peut
réellement contrer ce que l'État
souhaite nous imposer et c'est une
victoire je pense maintenant l'avenir
est devant nous nous devons tous
travailler non pas à une absorption
parce que le risque est aussi là c'est
que nous voyons l'arrivée de la
casquille avec sa force nous sommes une
intercommunalité qui n'a que quelques
mois et nous voulons justement qu'il y
ait une fusion et que tout cela pour
l'intérêt de l'ensemble des personnes
qui habitent et l'ensemble des villes
bien évidemment parce que l'important
c'est aussi les conséquences pour le
quotidien pour les habitants qui
habitent aussi bien Villepreux que
Maurepas exactement plaisir les clés ou
Saint-Quentin ou même Coignières si vous
êtes obligé finalement d'y rester ça on
le verra dans les prochains mois parce
qu'on vous aviez entendu tout à l'heure
sur votre contestation pour les clés
vous en attendez quoi également garder
votre identité déjà aussi ça c'est
important de garder notre identité mais
je pense que justement en étant plus
nombreux on a plus de chance de la de la
conserver donc ça c'est mon point de vue
donc je suis très contente de rejoindre
cette intercommunalité le conseil
municipal délibéré en juin 2011 dans ce
sens on est en 2015 donc c'est le début
d'une nouvelle aventure et comme
Stéphane comme mes collègues on attend
maintenant avec impatience parce que le
calendrier pourrait quand même très
contraint et d'après les informations on
se dispose il semblerait que il ne soit
pas d'actualité de le au moins pour les
compétences obligatoires de de différer
ce calendrier et donc de se mettre
autour de la table pour voir qu'ensemble
comment on va pouvoir porter des projets
communs et comment on va pouvoir
travailler ensemble et comme vous l'avez
dit parce que les citoyens ont été très
peu associés à cette affaire d'autant
plus que nous c'était une
intercommunalité provisoire donc c'est
très difficile à expliquer aux gens
comment quelque chose pour un homme et
que dans un an on recommence à faire
autre chose etc il va falloir aussi que
le citoyen soit associé à toute à toute
cette à toutes ces démarches des
compétences justement il va falloir
aménager pour que tout le monde s'y
retrouve aujourd'hui à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines le
développement économique aménagement
urbanisation équilibre social de
l'habitat politique de la ville santé
gestion des grands réseaux gestion des
culturel ça fait beaucoup de compétences
vous souhaitez que ce schéma là
s'applique aux autres communes faites
attention toutes les oreilles sont
il est il est temps de se mettre
maintenant autour de la table puisque
jusqu'à présent il fallait qu'on ait
vécu cette menace qui même qui peser sur
nous sur les 800000 habitants
aujourd'hui il est clair que les
communes qui sont représentées autour de
cette table à l'exception de Henri Payet
bien sûr avait déjà manifesté leur
intention de pouvoir rejoindre la
communauté de l'agglomération depuis
plusieurs années ce que on fait là et je
l'avais dit à l'occasion d'une série de
vœux en 2012 j'ai dit c'est dommage
qu'on perde du temps parce que on sera
dans cette configuration là dans les
années qui viennent on a perdu beaucoup
de temps c'est un petit peu dommage mais
c'était la position de la majorité
précédente au niveau de la côté d'agglo
là maintenant moi ce que je souhaite
c'est qu'on se mette tous autour de la
table et au niveau des compétences vous
allez discuter vous allez être ferme et
vous allez me dire le modèle c'est celui
de 50 ans les autres communes vont
devoir être ABS
j'ai jamais fonctionné de cette façon là
parce que avant d'être à moi je pense
que c'est intéressant
je suis même aussi et donc et donc étant
mère je ne veux pas imposer à mes
collègues de merde ce que je vous
souhaiterais pas que l'on m'impose moins
sur ma sur ma commune donc moi
aujourd'hui j'ai toujours été dans le
partage dans l'intelligence sauf que on
doit aussi appliquer la loi il y a des
compétences obligatoires mais ces
compétences elles sont appliquées et ce
qui est optionnel au nom discutera et on
verra jusqu'où on va la seule chose
c'est que on part là de situation qui
sont bien différentes nous sommes nous
dans une intervalualité très très forte
très poussée notre intégration est
terminale est de 50%. alors que on va
dire dans les communes qui sont
représentées ici et l'État 0.5 voilà
vous voyez que c'est trop pour 50 ans en
Yvelines il faudrait revoir
c'est le résultat c'est le résultat mais
il est vrai que aujourd'hui la
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin c'est doté de certaines
compétences optionnelles qui va
peut-être falloir que nous revoyons
parce que nous n'aurons plus les moyens
de pouvoir financer toutes ces
compétences quel type de compétences au
nom du scooter après attendez j'ai pas
j'ai pas le dire aujourd'hui je dois la
question
justement qui vous semblent
nécessaire
important je crois c'est comme disait
mes collègues c'est l'identité aussi des
collectivités aujourd'hui on a en face
de nous des citoyens qui s'interroge qui
commence à se poser des questions
réelles puisqu'on communique malgré tout
même si c'est à minima et il est
important de leur donner des réponses
des réponses aussi sur toutes les
interrogations qui peuvent se poser tant
au niveau de la fiscalité que des
compétences parce que c'est pas
uniquement les habitants c'est aussi les
agents des villes qui se demandent à
quelle sauce ils vont être mangés est-ce
qu'effectivement ils vont être intégrés
dans une grande intercommunalité qu'on
va être obligé de virer pas mal de monde
pour être un peu trivial donc tout ça il
faut que nous on en soit compétent et
j'aime beaucoup Michel quand
effectivement il est maire donc c'est
très bien tout cela et nous on a aussi
cette responsabilité là aujourd'hui de
de savoir tout mettre à plat de façon à
ce que on puisse protéger à la fois même
si on a une double casquette mais
protéger à la fois notre collectivité
dans tous les sens du terme et rejoindre
je dirais la question et cette grande
intercommunalité peut-être que le nom va
changer parce que comme on va arriver ce
serait sympa de la dynamisme
bien évidemment je ne partage je m'en
excuse auprès d'eux je ne partage rien
de ce qui a été dit autour de cette
table en ce moment même
c'est parfaitement clair pour moi depuis
92 je dénonce la terminalité c'est une
folie et c'est inscrit dans le ciel de
France de faire disparaître le 36000
communes de France qui sont des communes
de proximité avec des élus avec des élus
de proximité les compétences je vais
vous dire tout de suite je m'en fous de
toute manière les mères n'auront plus
aucune compétence à Coignières la
communauté commune des étangs me palpent
tout l'argent que j'ai tout je suis
content
je suis comme du temps de la chrétienne
République où les Français à étendre la
main à Washington pour avoir de l'argent
et bien moi j'en suis à temps de la main
à côté comme une des étangs pour pouvoir
fonctionner alors je suis la deuxième
ville la plus réputée
tout le travail que j'ai fait pendant 30
ans donc les ingrédients de rejoindre 50
ans non seulement excusez-moi je vais
être trivial non seulement me pique tout
mon fric mais en plus de ça on ne peut
pas on me prend toutes les compétences
qui ont un certain intérêt je suis
désolé les maires sont appelés à
disparaître tu dis que maire demain tu
ne le sera plus quand je ne sais pas
parce que c'est la logique c'est la
logique c'est la logique du système et
qu'est-ce qui restera au maire parce que
ne le repas on trouvera toujours
quelqu'un pour prendre le poste pour
gérer des couches culottes pour gérer
l'état civil mais l'essentiel
toute la carrière qui est la mienne 30
ans de mère à Coignières et bien c'est
bien évidemment d'avoir toutes les
compétences que j'avais gérer le
logement gérer l'économie gérer le
territoire etc etc demain il me restera
plus rien de tout ça il faudra que je
communique
35 conseillers communautaires où je
serai minoritaire bien évidemment et où
et c'est ça qui est extrêmement
important et bien c'est que en France je
suis désolé actuellement il y a 34000
communes de moins de je sais pas 2000
habitants c'est-à-dire donc des mers
sans étiquette qui se manque qui se
mouillent pas dans la politique et bien
demain
qu'est-ce qui va se passer les
intercommunalités avec des clochers à 20
km les uns des autres je vous dis pas la
proximité et bien les maires demain
je dirais les partis politiques plutôt
où on s'emparer des intervaux et on va
complètement politiser l'ensemble du
territoire français avec tout ce que
cela comporte quand on sait je dirais ce
que les Français
cette crainte et on y coté milliard
aussi de la disparition des communes de
l'absorption des compétences la
fiscalité le risque est là mais ce qu'il
faut voir c'est qu'il aurait été encore
pire avec une intercommunalité de 800000
là nous gardons avec 230 000 et je
l'espère les possibilités de proximité
avec les élus et c'est le moment de
cette monsieur de remettre tout à plat
et justement que les intercommunalités
se recentre sur les missions propres que
les villes doivent avoir l'eau
l'assainissement les ordures ménagères
et peut-être laisser les autres
compétences plus optionnelles pour que
les mers gardent la proximité avec les
habitants je pense que c'est quelque
chose de très très important je dirais
encore une chose sur l'enjeu qu'il y a
dans cette nouvelle structure qui va se
créer je pense que les habitants de nos
villes sont inquiets sont inquiets
surtout des conséquences budgétaires de
ces nouvelles
il faut absolument que nous travaillons
tous ensemble et c'est l'occasion dans
un contexte où l'État se désengage
réfléchissons ensemble avec un objectif
prioritaire faire de ces
intercommunalités des opportunités de
réduction des coûts la question des
finances justement je voulais juste un
petit peu oui bien sûr la question des
finances déjà pour réaliser nos budgets
et c'est on a du mal à voir de la
lisibilité bien sûr que c'est une
crainte et surtout comme je disais avec
un calendrier qui est si contraint
après moi je rejoins que effectivement
oui la disparition des communes peut
être moi je rejoins sur le devenir de la
commune c'est une c'est une réelle
préoccupation mais après tout dépend
aussi de l'intérêt communautaire
l'intérêt communautaire va définir aussi
les compétences et donc dans cet intérêt
communautaire il y a des compétences par
exemple on pense moi j'ai un souhait en
matière de transport etc qui sont des
compétences que de toute façon une deux
ou trois communes ne peuvent pas se
voilà payer des réseaux de transport
c'est certain que j'espère plus nombreux
on pourra aussi peut-être comment dire
entamer des différentes démarches pour
essayer de d'avancer l'agenda pour la
réalisation de la ligne cette fameuse
ligne verte la ligne 18 qui est si
importante au développement de tout ce
secteur sur les compétences pour morpa
demain ça va changer quoi l'intégration
à 50 ans en Yvelines alors moi je voilà
je partage aussi ce que disent mes
collègues moi l'intercommunalité est
toujours été quelque chose de très
positif pour moi
et je pense que ce sera très positif en
tout cas pour la ville de Maurepas qui
n'avait pas fait partie d'interconnalité
depuis 1984 ça a changé seulement à
partir du 1er janvier 2014 absolument et
on fonctionne déjà en intercommunalité
avec 50 ans un exemple c'est les
transports aussi en commun et avec
également le pont le dédoublement du
pont Guy Schuller qui qui va avoir lieu
dans quelques mois ça va commencer dans
quelques mois et qui est financé en très
grande partie par la comédie avec la
version de Saint-Quentin et une petite
partie par Maurepas tout seul on n'aura
pas pu le faire donc voilà là aussi à la
gare de la les enjeux vraiment de
territoires et d'avenir sur des
investissements très lourds doivent être
portées que par une intercommunalité
puissante et c'est pour ça qu'il est
important d'avoir un territoire qui
génère également des sources de richesse
important d'avoir un territoire
dynamique qui amène des entreprises
parce que c'est ça aussi qui crée des
richesses et je pense que 50 ans et
l'opportunité en tout cas pour les
enjeux d'avenir de nos villes voilà je
pourrais simplement apporter de
témoignages qui est le mien puisque je
fais partie de cette intercommodalité
depuis très longtemps j'en étais
vice-président j'en suis j'en suis
vice-président ça m'a pas empêché
d'avoir de beaux projets dans ma ville
et ça m'empêche pas aussi quand je vais
dans toutes les villes de Saint-Quentin
de voir les mers avec de beaux projets
l'intervernité n'a jamais fait
disparaître les communes au contraire
chacune a gardé son identité et je pense
qu'on est tous très très attachés il
suffit d'aller j'ai fait toutes les
cérémonies de vœux j'ai pas vu mère qui
était mécontent d'être dans une
intercommunalité parce que je crois
aujourd'hui
mais toi
donc aujourd'hui sur 50 et quel que soit
quel que soit leur couleur politique
jamais personne aujourd'hui ne va vous
dire que il souhaite sortir de
l'intercommunalité parce que on
travaille ensemble on sait être
intelligent et je crois que aujourd'hui
le temps des grands de querelles de
clocher est terminé parce que les enjeux
sont tout à fait différents et
aujourd'hui on est bien conscient des
capacités financières et qui sont de
moins en moins importantes chacun notre
niveau que on a envie justement de
vraiment réussir notre mutualisation
justement
je suis totalement opposé à cette idée
on nous a vendu l'interco en nous disant
qu'on avait mutualiser les moyens
diminuer les impôts des Français
résultat 2006 Philippe Seguin Cours des
comptes
l'interpolidité alors que la France
était à la moitié on a terminé 4
milliards de plus d'impôts locaux bon et
ça continue j'étais hier à côté
sur les finances on va être dans
l'obligation d'augmenter nos impôts
c'est parfaitement clair des enjeux
quelques minutes encore
dans un TGV celui qui pilote le TGV
c'est le préfet d'Aubigny là qui est à
la tête de la machine là il y a ensuite
la CRCI parlant celle-là par qui
a-t-elle été désignée partie a-t-elle
été élue moi quand j'étais en CDCI j'ai
été élu par mes paires là c'est
l'opacité la plus totale pour la
commission
je voudrais juste s'il vous plaît
ont été élus par les CDCI donc les avais
ici
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit très
pertinent
Bertrand Houillon également officiel
dans la minorité à l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines élu
minoritaire de gauche et ils avaient une
autre proposition juste pour conclure
cette émission c'était de se tourner
vers le plateau de Saclay eux ils
évoquaient cette possibilité comme étant
une ouverture plus tournée vers l'avenir
et pas un retour dans le passé dans le
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines historique
avec leur réintégration des autres
communes juste pour conclure
définitivement sur cette question là ça
te laisse n'était pas l'avenir
je pense que aller vers plaisir les clés
Villepreux Maurepas quoi dire pour moi
c'est par retour vers le passé c'est
aller vers l'avenir aussi ce sont des
territoires aussi comme beaucoup de
projets à la avec la CAPS très bien sauf
que la minorité actuelle de la
communauté de l'aggloude a déposé aucun
amendement ce sens donc si on veut aller
jusqu'au bout encore faut-il le prouver
donc là il y a eu aucun amendement
déposé dans ce sens-là donc ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'on a un discours
mais après lorsqu'il faut agir on n'est
pas là en allant vers 50 ans en Yvelines
je vous laisse 15 secondes
un article je dirais qui s'intitule
territoriale à déni de démocratie alors
donc pour tous les téléspectateurs qui
veulent en savoir plus
article là qui trouveront certainement
certainement en ligne juste pour un
dernier tour de table pour conclure 50
ans en Yvelines c'est l'avenir
évidemment
c'est l'avenir
mais ça fait longtemps qu'on en parle
par plaisir et dans cette dynamique
depuis pas mal de temps et je rejoins à
ce que dit Michel logis tout à l'heure
ça a beaucoup traîné et on sait très
bien pourquoi on va pas revenir dessus
il reste très peu de temps pour
s'organiser parce que il faudra moins
d'un an les prochaines réunions ce sera
pour quand
on sera très vigilant que ce que cette
nouvelle organisation puisse vraiment
mutualiser réellement des services parce
que c'est vrai que la Cour Régionale des
Comptes donc dans son rapport dit que
les intercommunalités ne créent des
dépenses supplémentaires et une
rationalisez pas donc voilà donc c'est
un défi que nous aurons à relever tous
ensemble
Grégory
et l'avenir qu'il faut maintenant tout
ce travail ensemble
dans des projets communs en respectant
évidemment l'identité de nos communes
parce que voilà ça devait être une force
avec les enjeux qui nous attendent
notamment comme le disait la mère des
clés sous bois c'est de baisser la
dépense publique voilà il faut de ces
intercommunalités
merci à tous d'être venu pour cette ce
premier plateau consacré à
l'intercommunalité au futur de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et encore des
discussions on l'a entendu qui vont
s'engager le 7 8 politique reviendra le
10 février il sera forcément question
des élections départementales très bonne
soirée